هزه ربما مقاربه للهزات التي وقعت خلال
يوم السادس والسابع من فبراير انقطعت
الاضواء هنا فقط اريد ان اريك انا اماما
كنت امام مدينه خيام انشات ولكن الارض
اهتزت هذا الجسر القريب من هنا سمعنا
اصوات لانفجارات وسمعنا اصوات لانهيار بعض
الابنيه في مدينه
انطاكيا استمر الزلزال لاكثر من عشرين
ثانيه بشده نحن كنا واقفين على الارض
اهتزت تماما اصوات الصراخ اصوات البناء
الابنيه التي انهارت يبدو ان هناك عدد من
الابنيه يبدو انها سقطت غالبا الابنيه
التي كانت متضرره بشكل كبير من الزلزال
الكهرباء كما يريكم الزميل يصور قطعت في
كامل المدينه فرق الانقاذ اضافه الى وحدات
من الجيش كانت قريبه من مدينه الخيام هذه
المنشاه على اطراف المدينه بدات بالتحرك
باتجاهي مدينه انطاكيا وان كانت المدينه
خاليه تماما الا من فرق الانقاذ هذا هذه
المحله القريبه من المدينه هناك بعض
السكان الذين ما زالوا يعيشون في هذه
البيوت